Pretty cool adventure, huh. Big long road trip adventure through space.
Even ran into Space Beth, maybe that'll happen more often. Let's not overdo it.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my Rick and Morty season 5 episode 2 video
there were so many Easter eggs, references,
it was way more meta than episode 1.
So we'll break it all down.
You're brand-new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes, be sure to subscribe
to get them.
We're doing a giveaway for Rick and Morty
merch all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and just leave your favorite Easter egg from
the episode on the video careful for spoilers
if you have not see the episode yet we'll
start at the beginning and work our way through
shot by shot doing Easter eggs and moments
I'll number these as we go along to stay organized
starting with the title of the episode Mortyplicity
which is a reference to the 1990s Michael
Keaton movie multiplicity the plot of the
episode is loosely similar to the plot of
that movie in that Michael Keaton during the
film creates a bunch of clones of himself
to do work make his life easier.
But in the clones go off the rails.
It doesn't turn into quite the bloodbath it
did during this rick and Morty episode, you
could also call this episode the war of the
decoys, the one with all the decoys, because
they want you to believe the real version
the family was off planet the whole time hanging
out with space Beth the also in the episode
and a very ambiguous way to make you wonder
if maybe that's another version of the duplicates
in the can start the cycle all over again
will get to that in the second, you could
also think of this episode is like a highlander episode
There can only be one Rick and Morty family.
There were a lot of highlander references
a lot of deep cuts for that movie in fun fact,
Clancy Brown who played the Kurgan during
that movie has also been in two different
Rick and Morty episodes as different characters,
he played risotto Groupon during the whirly
dirly conspiracy, season three episode five
in the during season four episode six he played
a person at the bar on the train complaining
about getting revenge on rick the cold open
of the episode starts with the decoy family
of rick and Morty eating breakfast making
a plan to kill the Christian god.
Who Rick says is real, he's been asleep for
thousands of years and were going to go wake
him up and kill him mob style.
If you really want to get technical about
this.
Like does God actually exist in them Rick
and Morty universe all the versions of rick
all the duplicates have the same level of
intellect as the original C137 Rick the created them
So if this fake Rick is saying the Christian
god is real and he believed it.
That means that he's now canon to the rick
and Morty universe.
They did a version of Zeus during season four.
So there have been god like beings that Rick
has fought before are mythological figures
that are believed to be gods.
Even during this episode, he refers to himself
or one of the decoys refers to himself as
a God, which is been a running bit since the
beginning of the show.
They don't call that out very often the like
during season three episode one Morty is trying
to tell summer he's not a god.
He just really messed up demon then this her
to set the recurring jokes throughout the
episode, they hit in all the different encounters
the different duplicates have something always
happens to tip them off and they realize that
either they're copies their duplicates or
someone comes in to kill them before they
can find out this time it's Jerry saying that
he's got a job interview in the idea of Jerry
having a successful career is so abnormal
in the rick and Morty universe that rick realizes
something is fundamentally wrong then we see
our first versions of another group of decoys
disguised as squid aliens coming to kill them
although they don't actually reveals that it's the
copies underneath the costumes to later in the episode
This is one of those episodes where they have
a bit within a bit within a bit.
The whole idea though.
Which Rick is the real C137 Rick with all
the fake outs that happened during the episode.
And even at the end of the episode with space
Beth is the you used to be able to say that
the real see one 37 rick Sanchez could be
identified by the drool on his mouth in the
funny thing about the drool is that the only
version of rick in the episode that you see
would drool on his lip is actually one of
the wooden versions of rick the one is her
trying to help everyone, which is clearly
a fake, because is beta would last time we
actually saw a Rick with drool on his lip
in in episode was season four episode 10 then
they set up the bit with the Mr. always wants
to be hunted which they pay off at the end
of the episode with that version of rick also
breaking the fourth wall when he asks if they
set the bit earlier.
Like wait a minute to be set this up.
This rick says don't hug him to completion,
so I'll let you guess what would happen if
someone actually did that because they do
not answer the question by the end of the episode
So Mr. always wants to be hunted is still
alive before the events of the post credit
scene love the way they create more enemies
for the family in they just don't answer what
happens to them so they could always potentially
come back in some future bit I believe that
he's meant to be more of a parody of tickle
me Elmo like a dull like that the seems ago
real big deal at first, but then you get tired
of really fast.
Which he calls out.
Rick calls out there bits and tropes all the
time when they're making fun of them are referencing
them in episodes.
But this episode in particular got so meta,
that almost every single version of rick and
every single version of a family member had
some callout to some trope that they were
doing they start to set up all the fake outs
one right after the other with each new version
the family being revealed this fake.
This version gets in the car then they explained
the premise of the episode.
Rick says he created a bunch of duplicate
families as a buffer because of what happened
with space Beth during the events of season
four episode 10 in the finale was also meant
to be them setting up the space beth cameo
scene at the end of the episode.
Which itself is a sort of meta joke about
the Mr. always wants to be hunted asking if
they set up the payoff like did we set this
up in the answer is yes the actually did that
with several different bits during the episode
recurring gags, especially the running gag
about summer being the one in almost every
version of the family every version of the
duplicates that realize that they might be
fakes as well.
Like what if where the duplicates and then
they always had some big called like summer was right
the whole time.
The real reason for the duplicates before
it became a big Gagan plot of the episode
was because the galactic government during
season four was able to track down space beth
back to planet earth.
Where the rest of the family was living so
Rick wanted to create a buffer zone and as
they call that with the muppet versions at
the end of the episode, you created a see
of us because you're so afraid to lose us
reminding you that even though Rick doesn't
say it all the time.
He actually does really care about the family
but then in another fake out scene right after
they get finished explain the episode.
This family gets killed by a squid ship.
Which is another family in disguised who then
gets killed by another version the family
who then goes and tracks down another family
the whole when both joke about besieges the
big send up on the tropes of werewolves and
vampires then making fun of time traveling
Dracula saying that is not very interesting
seeing him go to prehistoric times.
Then another version of rick completely teased
up.
Like he is going to completely explain what
happened to best mom like hears all this information
the you've always wanted the past five seasons
the show.
Then the next version of rick gets Morty to
look inside his ass cheeks to T up a big far
joke makes another space beth reference say
that the mere suggestion that he could be
fake wouldn't break him the weight would break
Beth like it broke her when she was trying
to find out if she was the clone the funny
thing about all the fake outs to is that early
on in the episode, they stop for that brief
explainer with a whiteboard and they because
even though there's the mean about you haven't
be really smart to follow Rick and Morty this
episode in particular was a little bit harder
to follow if you weren't paying attention
really closely because the way they were using
all the fake outs later in the episode.
After a couple more.
Rick actually claims there's maybe like 4050
more versions of the family that they have
to go track down and kill I think I was actually
meant to be accurate like the total number
of duplicate versions of the family running
around on earth when rick barges in and says
analysis mode 80085.
That action makes boobs if you type it on
a calculator.
There were some classic rig singers in the
episode.
Like Beth even calls about.
Like I kind of expected it to be a funnier
joke Morty makes a Westworld joke and rick
follows up saying he's not supposed to have
sex with any of the duplicates, because if
you didn't see Westworld actually did Easter
eggs videos for all the seasons of Westworld.
So open a link for those in the description.
But one of the twist of Westworld season one.
At least was that the themepark the Westworld
Park was sort of a glorified brothel for uber
rich people to live out their wildest fantasies
later in the episode.
They also make an ex machina reference in
during that movie.
There's a bunch of robots that they create
and then have sex with we find out that Morty
can only finish himself to completion when
he uses the Yosemite T-shirt.
Which is gross feels appropriate for Morty
and they start to unravel the meta aspect
of the episode with the duplicates creating
their own duplicate families.
Without realizing that they themselves were
duplicates in the first place.
All the duplicates are supposed to be machine
mechanical traditional robot looking with
human skin on top basically like glorified
terminators that they took it to the nth degree
with this idea of the bit about the later
copies and copies of copies starting to degrade
in quality and eventually they were made of
wood and straw.
Even wicker which is actually pretty impressive
if you think about it.
An almost perfect replica of the family made
out of straw.
You may have also notice during the episode.
It felt like a lot of the jokes were recycled
jokes from earlier episodes.
Like the wooden glockenspiel Jerry abandoning
his family saying that I didn't ask for any of this
I can't remember which episode it's from but
that line is almost verbatim from a previous
episode with a similar bit at the beginning
of the episode when rick and Morty are yelling
at summer to shut up.
That's also a very season one season two.
Type of rick and Morty joke.
So it felt like they actually started to give
some of these a lesser copies of rick and
Morty like the more degrade in quality more
recycled jokes from previous episodes sort
of in keeping with the theme of them being
lesser copies.
Like were going to give you bad jokes that
are recycled because you are literally a recycle
character a copy of a copy of a copy when
rick asks beth if she's going to save every
stray cat, there's actually a stray cat version
of Morty inside pocket mortys.
And then Rick makes a blade runner reference
to Deckard having to hunt down all the replicants
and deactivate them could terminate them.
They keep calling back to summer being the
one to correctly guesses that they're also
decoys throughout most of the versions of
the family then when they hit up this version
the family they start to highlight the idea
of how other duplicates are also creating
duplicates of themselves the clue being that
ricks Boobs password does not work on this
Jerry then we meet the other duplicates the
created this version we find out that this
Rick's password is 8 = = D which spells out
a Dick if you type it on a calculator.
Which is on par with the Boobs password joke
Rick really reaching for the depot jokes in
this episode they have an almost identical
version of the scene that we just saw earlier
in the episode at this house.
Only this time is the ex machina reference
or just a couple small differences.
We learn that at least some of the duplicates
of Rick have guns inside their teeth I guess
is just the ricks.
Because during episode one last week Rick
said that all the beth and Jerry's teeth had
suicide capsules and them in some of the other
ricks do have the capsules in their teeth
to Rick calls out the prisoners dilemma.
Which is a game theory scenario for explaining
why two parties who might benefit from working
together, might not.
Even though it's in their best interest to
cooperate when this decoy talks about having
to eventually accept that one of them is the
decoy, that also sets up the bit later that
they pay off in the episode when things are
to escalate to the point where a ton a different
versions of the families all just accept it
and start killing themselves preemptively
once they charge each other though.
That's when things really start to go down
the rabbit hole like this her to escalate
the action of the episode another duplicate
Rick comes in kills them, then pulls out a
whiteboard explaining the episode again.
Like is that I think this is sort of check
in with the audience also because it started
to get so meta the like okay we want to make
sure very follows the plot of this.
When he mentions the Asimov cascade that's
actually reference to the three laws of robotics
in its part of the way the first law works.
Wherein a series of cascades is what happens
when things slowly go off the rails with a
robots functionality.
But in this context is about all the duplicates
creating the other duplicates creating this
chaos level scenario where everything just
erupts into pure madness this summer makes
fun of him, say decoy again because again,
it's a summer kind of realizing that they're
also probably decoys and this is all pointless,
then Rick makes a highlander reference.
There can be only one in doubles down on it
when the family has no idea what he's talking about
He demands that they rent the movie when this
is all over then drops a huge burn on Christopher
Lambert for not having a Scottish accent or
just a strange accent in general after replacing
Sean Connery's character who was the Spaniard
in that movie Rick sets up the bit with the
weird looking decoys like the straw decoy,
the wooden ones, the muppet decoys which themselves
were just costumes.
But saying that you get far enough down the
line and things really start to get weird
Rick shoots down Jerry's suggestion breaking
the fourth wall saying that if they were to
break into two groups, they'd have to engage
in a B story that he does want to keep track
of during the episode there are a couple different
ricks.
That may fourth wall breaks during the episode.
They said the whole squid decoy reveal when
this rick has them dress up in the really
crappy looking smelling cheap squid costumes
which apparently smell like a gym teacher
setting up the reveal that the squids were
duplicates the whole time.
Just some of them in really good quality costumes
that seemed real summer calls out the fact
they're probably decoys themselves again.
And reminds us that the family lives in Colorado.
They kind of revealed that a couple seasons
ago during season three when you see the map.
But Justin has also previously set a long
time ago that they're supposed to live somewhere
outside of Seattle Washington.
So take that for what you will.
It's kind of like a Simpsons scenario where
they're trying to be kind of ambiguous about
where the family lives every once in a while
the reference specific places Rick makes it
sound like he winds up sleeping with a lot
of alien races Queens by saying that he probably
slept with their queen and that's why the
squids are coming for them.
Even though these aliens themselves were total
fakes the whole time.
Just other copies of the family like I don't
know why they're attacking us random aliens
I probably slept with their queen like that
something that he does on the regular that
we see another version of rick in the garage
torturing a small creature to get it to poop
out something that looks like candy the music
that starts playing for that montage that
they T up is a copyright free version of the
sinnerman song from Thomas Crowne affair.
But it got used in a ton of movies and TV
shows, so you probably recognize the tune
from somewhere.
But it queues up the first big decoy killing
montage when they just go into a bunch of
different versions killing each other one
of the ricks find out that is the decoy by
pulling a chip out of his own brain.
I think the firmware version 6 reference here
is to denote that he's like the sixth generation
duplicate look at this point in the episode
were quickly working our way down the list
to the weird ones that Rick was referencing
down the generational ladder.
Copies of copies of copies and so on it almost
feels like summer cutting herself with a razor
blade a lengthwise down her arm is meant to
be an edgy summer joke.
Like maybe she cuts herself.
Until rick comes along and just rips her flesh
right off revealing she's a copy.
Like he didn't slice her arm deep enough.
Then this rick makes a bunch of libertarian
burns say the gonna go live in the woods off
the grid. Hunt rabbits and use little pieces
of gold bars that will cut off with a knife for money.
Rick does have a truce with the president.
But he hates all forms of government all political
parties there are a couple political jokes
later in the episode when the president shows
up for his cameo scene.
I'm not totally sure what these weird symbols
on all the trees are meant to represent so
if you think you know what they are just right
them blown the comments summer calls rick
out for succumbing to the it's too quiet trope.
Saying he didn't do the bit correctly in the
straw version of rick and his family feels
like they're meant to be a bit of a mixture
of classic horror movies like Hellraiser and
a little silence of the lambs with the flesh
suit that he's trying to make for each of
the family members.
Like will make suits for ourselves then will
be complete I love the barrel decoy version
of rick here to like straw in a barrel in
is implied that this rick who's torturing
them in to take their skin is the duplicate
was created by this barrel version of rick.
Like he himself is a lesser straw version
with no barrel the other Rick that he's already
skin calls him out on his bit.
Kill me if I ever get this arch.
Like this is dumb, so kill me if I ever get
this hackey.
Then they all get saved by that wooden doll
version of the family and as I said this is
the only rick in the episode with drool on
his lip.
He's also one of the few versions of rick
in the episode will.
And when we actually Steve is willing to help
other families.
Whereas most of the other duplicates were
shooting everyone on site you also notice
the because are supposed to be lower quality
wooden versions there voice boxes are lower
quality so the process of the actor's voices
to make them sound kind of crappy her tousle
of their commitment to a lot of these bits
to like the attention to detail the wooden
clock joke with the bird weapon that comes
out of his hand in tweets then retracts like
a clock and because this is a wooden version
of his family.
They also fly in a wooden ship.
It looks really old tiny they do the big reveal
on many many versions having banded together
as refugees.
Most of them look normal without any huge
differences.
I think to make it easier for them to animate
this part of the episode was their only a
couple weird versions during this part of
the episode.
This end of the whole glockenspiel Jerry post
credit scene with the varnish.
The whole idea being that you use varnish
on their wood bodies, it waterproofs them,
allowing them to go beyond the river as Jerry
says glockenspiel Morty makes a blackface
joke, then another Jerry actually calls out
how meta the episode is when the others try
to explain to a different Jerry about what's
actually going on with the squids.
Saying, yes, it is a lot like they really
went down the rabbit hole with the plot of
this episode we cut to completely different
versions who are in Mexico in the ocean doing
their bucket list.
By letting summer pee in the ocean.
Which feels like a callback to episode one
when rick said the purposefully crapped in
the ocean to spite Mr. Nimbus.
He makes a rule 34 reference.
Even though it's in the context of the Asimov
cascade scenario anywhere the family could
possibly use as a hiding place will be used
as a hiding place rule 34 is more famous for
being know that anything that can be turned
into will be turned into to give each of the
family members a couple quick references before
killing them off they should down Jerry's
idea of visiting all the major league ballparks
Morty has the idea to ask out a new version
of what sounds like Mexican Jessica at his
new Mexican school because that's where they
are now trying to hide out at least for a
little while Rick saying that even though
would be heartwarming they don't have time
for before they get incinerated.
It also feels like a callback to Morty never
actually having a chance to really get with jessica.
Like they called out at the end of episode
one where Jessica going full time god basically
says yes were going to try a couple more times
ultimately basically telling Morty that they're
never going to wind up together the set of
the whole bit with the starfox boss that's
meant to be a callback to rick and Morty season
four with the giant hologram this more specifically
a reference to the hologram ricks from season
four episode one that kept following around
Morty until he brought rick back in the final
boss from starfox game was basically like
a giant floating head just like Rick's head
here their house transforms activating all's
defenses, this happens with another version
of the house to like most of the houses are
all of the same, so every house has a version
of these kinds of defenses and capabilities
they could to a bunch of different versions
of weird looking families this one seems like
wicker versions of all the characters this
one seems like a metal skinned robot Rick
this is ceramic rick in the Arizona desert
with native American designs.
Like he's a planter only instead of a plant
inside his head.
He's got a gun then this giant hologram rick
calls himself out for doing so much exposition
while he's baiting them to all come get you
see all kinds of versions of his ship, like
the higher and lower quality squid versions.
Like the cosplay versions and in the high-tech
versions of the squid ship's their bunch of
regular versions of his ship, remember earlier
in the episode.
He said, there are like 40 or 50
versions of the family around
earth them again are big Keith David cameo scene
He comes back is the president for a really
quick scene.
But they also brought him back for another
different episode later this season with the
giant turkey scene from the trailer I don't
which episode.
That's going to be.
But he will be back during this cameo scene
though we just kind of waves his hand of the
problem is as I have any of those rick duplicates
voted for me anyway.
Then makes a joke about the electoral college
being terrible and asked for a diet coke.
Which itself is a trump joke.
If you didn't hear the diet coke stories of
this is actually a real thing the people found out about
after he left office apparently inside the
oval office.
He had a button attached to the resolute desk
when he pressed it a little butler would come
out and bring him a diet coke all the time
throughout the day, there were a couple different
people visit they had meetings with him where
he would press the button and even see this
will person can run out with a diet coke every
once in a while so he had it diet coke button
inside the oval office.
That's why the rick and Morty present is calling
for the diet coke then this Rick gives all
the family members weapons that they had previously
asked him for in earlier episodes.
Like Morty had asked rick for a laser whip
during season 4I think it was.
Summer asked him for a lightsaber in the tiny
gun he gives Jerry is a men in black reference
to the cricket like a tiny little gun with
a super high output.
This part of the episode is really like the
burn phase 1 a trying to get rid of as many
duplicates as possible because it is the end
of the episode.
They want to wrap things up pretty quickly
they cut to the muppet version of the rick family
But there costumes which I feel like itself
is kind of a meta Jim Henson reference.
Because some of the larger puppets that he
created were physical costumes the people
would climb into to operate these this part
of the episode also call out some of the themes
again say oh Rick you created all these copies
because you're so afraid to lose the family
so you really do care about us then they go
fight it out with the survivors or so they
believe of their final survivors with Summer
makes a reference to doing Mali with the duplicate
before she dies I believe.
That's a callback to previous season where
she said something similar like she wanted
to do Mali before she died.
She kills herself really slowly though that
is hardcore.
But summer is been pretty hard-core previous
seasons of the show.
They make the joke about the Morty's being
really concerned with any versions of summer
killing herself this rick tries to one up
the other by saying that even though it's
true that your private smartest person the
universe.
I'm better because I am a God.
Which is another callback to that wooden version
of death in the cave referencing rick as an
unloving god who created them all vented this
version of rick has a suicide tooth in then
they pay off that Mr. always wants to be hunted
joke after this version of rick repents like
oh I finally love all you everything is going
to be good now get to be much nicer grandfather
and they do not address what happens to this
doll at the end of the episode.
Like he some creepy Mr. poopy butthole looking
version of tickle me Elmo that really really
wants to be hunted so he just another potential
threat to bring back in future joke, then
they pay off the space beth reference from
the beginning of the episode making you think
this is supposed to be the real version the
family has been away having and adventure
with her the whole episode, but again.
There's no drool on his mouth, so is he the
real version of Rick is this the real family
because the joke that he goes out on is by
revealing the duplicates in the family has
that similar reaction like duplicates what
as if they're trying to T up another cycle
of the bit in the be more duplicates revealed
see the let me know in the comments if you
actually think that this version is supposed
to be the real family.
I think they just purposely try to be ambiguous
about it to mess with people's heads then
during the post credit scene, they reveal
what happened to glockenspiel Jerry he survived
in the river, then was used to make a beaver
dam and as a nest in the going to the big
highlander theme music montage.
The song is Queens who wants to live forever.
Which plays during the highlander movie as
this version of Jerry goes on to live forever
through different eras of human history, like
post apocalyptic, where you see animals walking
around and talking.
The woodpecker man pecks at his wood head
because he's a woodpecker like a said the
rick and Morty animators have a lot of commitment
to this bit, then he gets turned into a mirror
frame at a futuristic cowboy bar and I love
how he starts to question the logic of some
of these successive bits like wait cowboys
in the future what was going on here they
burn him in the street and then he wakes up
again in a Christ on the cross joke with the
alien Jesus being nailed up to him.
Like Jerry is the cross itself.
Which he also questions again.
Like wait a minute.
Romans Christianity again.
We lose back around again were doing it all
over again the next week is going to be a
big captain planet bit will do a trailer video
for that tomorrow if you spotted any other
Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't mention
during the video just right them blown the comments
That was so dense with meta references in
Easter eggs bits within bits within bit you
comply watch the episode 45 times and still
find new stuff everyone click here for my
Rick and Morty season five episode one video
and click here for my full Loki episode 3 video
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!